أجنبي
[موسيقى]
أعطى أفضل إجابة تركت السؤال
وأقول بالفعل ما هو
أفضل طريقة
للتفكير في الأمر ، نعم إنها مسؤولية
إنها مسؤولية لطيفة
على الأقل أعرفها كل صباح عندما أضع
لماذا أقف ولماذا أفعل الكثير من
الإدارة التي هي متعبة للغاية
لدينا بالطبع مشاكل هيكلية
كل من يعمل في الثقافة يعرف أن
الكلية التي تعمل في الثقافة في
مجتمعاتنا ليست ممتعة أبدًا ، ولكن من
الصعب جدًا العثور على المال اللازم لذلك
احصل على الدعم لديك للتواصل هنا
وهناك لديك لرعاية
الأشياء ، كل هذا بالطبع متعب ولكن
المرح هو أنه في الوقت الحاضر يمكنك
خاصة مع الفن الإسلامي يمكنك
إثراء عقل الناس وقلب الأغنياء
وغالبًا ما يكون لديهم في  المتحف
عندما يذهبون للقيام بجولات
وأرى كيف بدأوا في الحب فجأة
وجدوا أنهم بدأوا في حب الفن الإسلامي
ولم يسمعوا به من قبل ولم أكن
أعرف هذا رائع
وهذا أمر محفز للغاية بحيث يمكنك  أعط
في مجتمعنا شيئًا هو أه
بكل هذه الأشياء ، لذا فهي
مسؤولية نعم ، لكنها
فرصة كبيرة في الوقت الحاضر لإضافة شيء
مهم جدًا لمحادثاتنا الثقافية
عندما نتحدث عن
العولمة عندما نتحدث عن
التفاعل ونتحدث عن الحروب
والإرهاب عندما نتحدث  نتحدث عن
مجتمعاتنا كيف تتغير وأن
نقول مرحبًا أن هناك أهمية كبيرة
لهذه الثقافات وكيف أنها ساعدتنا في
تطوير ما نحن عليه اليوم ، نعم ، نعم